dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here today
we're going to talk about a procedural
algorithm but first of all what does
procedural mean procedural graphics is
an exciting subfield of computer
graphics where instead of storing a lot
of stuff information is generated on the
fly
for instance in photorealistic rendering
we're trying to simulate how digital
objects would look like in real life we
usually seek to involve some scratches
on our digital models and perhaps add
some pieces of bump or dirt on the
surface of the model to obtain this we
can just ask the computer to not only
generate them on the fly but we can also
edit them as we desire we can also
generate cloudy skies and many other
things where only some statistical
properties have to be satisfied like how
many clouds we wish to see and how puffy
they should be which would otherwise be
too laborious to draw by hand your
scholars after all we don't have time
for that there are also computer games
where the levels we can play through are
not predetermined but also generated on
the fly according to some given logical
constraints this can mean that the
labyrinth should be solvable or the
level shouldn't contain too many enemies
that would be impossible to defeat the
main selling point is that such a
computer game has potentially an
infinite amount of levels in this paper
a technique is proposed to automatically
generate procedural yarn geometry the
yarn is a piece of thread from which we
can solve garments the authors
extensively studied parameters in
physical pieces of yarns such as
twisting and hairiness and try to match
them with a procedural technique so for
instance if in a sudden trepidation we
wish to obtain a realistic looking piece
of cotton rayon or silk in our light
simulation programs we can easily get a
unique sample of a chosen material which
will be very close to the real deal in
terms of these intuitive parameters like
hairiness and we can not only get as
long or as many of these as we desire
but we can also edit them according to
our artistic vision the solutions are
valid
against photographs and even CT scans I
always emphasize that I really like
these papers where the solutions have
some connection to the real world around
us this one is super fun indeed the
paper is a majestic combination of
beautifully written mathematics and
amazing looking results make sure to
have a look and you know we always hear
these news where other youtubers have
problems with what is going on in their
comment section while not here with our
fellow scholars have a look at the
comments section of our previous episode
just absolutely beautiful I don't even
know what to say it feels like a secret
hideout of respectful and scholarly
conversations it's really amazing that
we are building a community of fellow
scholars humble people who wish nothing
else than to learn more thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time
you